this week on world stories attacks on
African students in India on the rise
the house lived in by a civil rights
legend crosses the Atlantic but first we
travel to France a country in election
fever the town of inner bomber has been
far-right National Front territory since
2014 this former coal mining town used
to be a stronghold of the Socialist
Party but in 2014 after decades of high
unemployment and a corruption scandal
that hit the former mayor the floor
Nationale swept to power in Anan boomer
[Music]
as soon as we took over we lowered local
taxes and improved local services no
other municipality in the region has
done that or the others are just
increasing taxes without doing anything
for their citizens we have a pragmatic
way of operating which is devoid of any
ideology we make it work by saving money
and being more efficient local
unemployment remains high one in five is
out of work but many inhabitants still
feel the front of Chanel is taking
better care of them regardless of the
party's anti-immigration stance my
husband had serious health problems so
we apply for new social housing because
our elevator just wouldn't work the old
mayor just ignored me but then I met the
for national leader marine lepen here at
the market and she told me to send her
my documents so I did even though I
didn't think she would help us
two weeks later had loads of different
offers to dissociate a mop like the
furnace you know once our jobs to go to
the French it's right not to want to
take in all the immigrants we have
enough financial problems and need to
look after ourselves but not everybody
here feels supported by the four
Nationale this a group is being expelled
from its premises without the town
providing new officers
the anti-poverty NGO says it's a way to
get rid of them because some of the
members are left-wing professionals Eric
Mazur now remember more in my last
conversation with the mayor he very
clearly said that he thought we had a
political agenda but I told him we
didn't we have nothing to do with our
members political orientation we are
politically neutral the opposition also
has a tough time in the City Council
they number six
against the front us in our 29 members
the opposition is literally getting
shouted down by the majority the phone
arsenal is using in as a showcase and
has brought in its top talents it's very
difficult to stand our ground in such
circumstances and convince anybody to
vote for us this is a real war machine
the front as soon as members say they
are just defending themselves against a
very aggressive opposition
[Music]
India is a magnet for African students
thousands many from Nigeria and Sudan
study there but attacks last month
against African students near Delhi have
cast a shadow we have this report Abdul
Rahim machmood came to India three years
ago from Nigeria to study Business
Administration he was drawn by the
country's reputation for a low-cost high
quality education but the recent mob
attack against African students near
this private university close to Delhi
has left him and his friends shaken
Abdul Rahim who lives off campus says he
stayed indoors for a whole week after
the attack fearing further violence I
have to be looking over my shoulders
I don't feel secure this itching is
dangerous out there
foreign students account for a large
chunk of the private universities
revenue authorities are alarmed the
recent racist attacks could threaten its
funding and tarnish India's image as a
global education hub definitely we are
worried that the fewer students might
come because of this incident and and we
have to do our damage control in the
terms of we have to introspect we have
to see how it has happened why it has
happened the education sector is a big
part of India's growing ties with Africa
experts say wooing African students is a
way for Delhi to build on its soft power
and help expand India's bilateral trade
and economic footprint in the continent
today we have a situation where India is
engaged in a certain amount of bilateral
trade with African countries India
exports a fair amount to African
countries and it is importing the
equivalent of primary material primary
resources as for instance in the
hydrocarbon sector now if we have a
situation where the average African
student is unsafe my sense is that
Indian investment in Africa as also
Indian exports to Africa would be
adversely impacted abdul rahim has a few
months to go before he finishes his
studies and heads back
he says the attack and his experience in
India has left him disillusioned and
determined not to come back any African
that will that is considering to come to
India will have to think twice now
because of this incident so this is the
reality it has really affected our
relationship with the with India India
has its work cut out to convince
international students that it's still a
safe bet
for people smugglers the border fence
between the US and Mexico is good for
business but for the families / it the
barrier stands for painful separation
[Music]
after a long separation a tender reunion
at the border fence era clips in the
United States his mother in Mexico
he can't visit her she has no visa this
is the only way they can see each other
in person I can I crash in Mexico so
since seven months having seen her and
today I got a day to see her I feel
really good but I don't know why doncha
wants to make a while there's a lot of
families here in sukhasana Nogales they
don't cross and there's only place to
see the parents or the family Sheriff
Tony Estrada sees these types of scenes
daily he was born in Nogales Mexico but
grew up on the US side of the border in
Nogales Arizona he says the two cities
share close ties and is skeptical of a
border war obviously a big concrete wall
that maybe 20 30 feet high it's not
something we're really looking forward
to you know it just continued to
separate us more and more and besides
that it's not the answer in recent years
millions of dollars have been spent on
enhancing border security but hundreds
of thousands still tried to make the
crossing every year here in Arizona most
travel through deserts and canyons
breakfast in a migrant shelter on the
other side of the border most of the
people here were just deported from the
US this morning after trying to cross
the border illegally they come from
Mexico Guatemala or Honduras they risk
everything and paid smugglers large sums
of money now they are not sure what will
happen to them I have three or four
family members there that I've never met
so I'd like to meet them I crossed the
border with a smuggler left me in the
desert then the u.s. Border Patrol found
and arrested me I was held for twenty
days and today they brought me here
father Shankar all hears these kinds of
stories again and again the Jesuit
priest is in charge of the migrant
center day after day he sees traumatized
people Carol says the drug cartels are
firmly in control of the people
smuggling here to change that they need
more than just a border war so there
really needs to be serious investment in
economic development I would say
especially in southern Mexico and in the
northern part of Central America so that
people can have a dignified life where
they live and they don't feel like
they're forced to migrate to leave their
homes to find a better life for now he
and our volunteers tried to help the
people here as best they can with advice
medicine and clothing he knows most will
try again to reach the United States
with a hope of a better life
our last report takes us to Berlin not
where you would expect to find a rather
modest Detroit clapboard house once home
to a famous human rights activist but
you'd be wrong
[Music]
2672 South Deacon Street Detroit this
was the house where Rosa Parks lived
after fleeing Alabama from Michigan only
it's not in Michigan anymore it's here
in the German capital when no one in the
u.s. showed interest in keeping it
standing the city of Detroit sold it for
$500 the fact that they sold it for $500
the American government thought that
this house was worth $500 it speaks
volumes it's actually evidence of an
enormous neglect New York native Ryan
Mendoza brought the house to Berlin
where it now stands in the district of
vetting following a long journey Rosa
Parks is nice Rhea McCauley seen here on
the left gave the house to Mendoza as a
gift last summer he had the house
dismantled and shipped to Berlin where
it now stands on his property
Fabian Mendoza who helped her husband
reassemble the house says the story of
Rosa Parks reflects the struggles of
many in her circumstance they went noise
because with the hope that they find a
better life and if it's an employment
that they can live the couple put up the
funds to transport the house to Berlin
where they were set on having it
reassembled as an exhibition the artists
hope that the house will eventually be
returned to the United States and stand
as a National Monument perhaps in one of
the gardens at the White House but for
now the spirit of Rosa Parks is present
in Berlin
[Music]
you